finally the moment the resolution is
adopted and without objection the motion
to reconsider is laid on the table the
articles of impeachment against Donald
Trump will now move from the House of
Representatives to the Senate House
Speaker Nancy Pelosi unveiled the team
that will lead the trial against Donald
Trump she insists her calculated full
week delay has paid off on December 18th
the House of Representatives impeached
the President of the United States an
impeachment that will last forever time
has revealed many things since then time
has been our friend in all of this
because hazard was yielded incriminating
evidence more truth into the public
domain Pelosi is referring to material
obtained from lespinasse an associate of
trumps personal lawyer Rudy Giuliani it
reveals previously unknown details about
efforts to push Ukraine into announcing
an investigation into Trump's political
rival Joe Biden interference into our
elections again he jeopardized our
national security he did all this for
his personal political gain the
Democrats delay was crucially about
pressuring Republicans to allow
witnesses to be called during the trial
but no witness deal has been reached
Republicans are united in their ongoing
dismissal of the entire process back
when this national nightmare began
Speaker Pelosi laid bare her attentions
and purely partisan agenda she told her
caucus that they needed to strike while
the iron is hot this was always an
exercise in raw partisan politics as the
house moved on impeachment Donald Trump
was signing phase one of his China trade
deal
he wants voters to see him as the stoic
president focused on things that matter
while Democrats continue their obsession
with bringing him down the Senate trial
is expected to begin in earnest next
Tuesday it's only the 3rd ever of a US
president if Democrats have their way
there could be some explosive moments
but it is the Republicans who control
the Senate they want all this to be over
as quickly as possible
Amanda Walker Sky News Washington